vva elle n'a pas pu tomber sur cher
public chers athlètes olympiques ou pas
le temps d l'objectif c'est la médaille
d'or c'est fini si je vous dis j omondi
tokyo ce qui aurait dû être dans quatre
fois et paris 2024 c'est dans un peu
moins de 1600 jours après l'échec de
2012 le tout paris et beaucoup de
politiques se sont félicité de
l'obtention de ces jeux en boxe crois
que j'avais lancé un ballon de hand
leur argument la france en pleine
lumière
des infrastructures pour le futur des
retombées économiques estimées entre 5,3
et 10,7 milliards d'euros d'ici 2034
selon le cds de limoges alors non c'est
pas par javelot et c'est les épreuves de
natation venez emplois non en fait ne
réagirait pas pour les projos les
françaises seront gagnants leurs
opposants eux dénoncent un endettement
inutile alors qui croire dans leurs
baskets
je crois que c'est un grande botte après
la passe d'armes macron hidalgo sur le
sponsoring de total et je vert et
durable sont ils vraiment réalisable
alors qu'un retour de flamme pour paris
2024 on en parle après le générique
[Musique]
bienvenue sur arte france pour un nouvel
épisode de l'autre match spécial jeux de
paris les jo-2020 tu 4 c'est dans moins
de 1600 jour êtes vous pour ou contre
l'organisation du plus grand événement
du sport au monde
on en parle sur ce plateau avec nos
invités armand de rands 1 g bonjour vous
êtes consultant international du sport
et de l'olympisme
vous avez notamment été ex conseiller
pour les jeux de nombreux jeux un de
sydney de nagui ou encore d'atlanta même
d'albertville en france les derniers
jours en france d'ailleurs c'était en 92
les jeux d'hiver et vous êtes l'auteur
du pari olympiques de 2024 chance ou
malédiction aux éditions vigot bonjour
merci d'être sur ce plateau jours à vos
côtés à frédéric viale membres du
collectif non aux jeux olympiques de
bonjour bonjour avant de rentrer dans le
vif du sujet dans le vif du débat je
vous propose un sondage réalisé sur les
roses réseaux sociaux via rt france sur
à peu près 3000 votants paris 2024 pour
ou contre les résultats pour 17% contre
83% résultats assez surprenants quand on
regarde les derniers sondages à l'époque
notamment à l'obtention des jeux de
paris avant de développer vos arguments
messieurs êtes vous pour ou contre
brièvement nous synthétiser votre pensée
frédéric moi je vais représenter le
contre parce que pour moi les jeux
olympiques c'est véritablement
l'expression du vieux monde c'est à dire
qui ne prend jamais en compte la
question climatique la question sociale
la question environnementale est donc je
suis contre votre position armand de
rands 1 g avant moi je suis tout à fait
le tour mais pas à n'importe quel prix
et il est hors de question qu'une chance
d'organiser d'organiser les jeux
olympiques se transforme en une
véritable malédiction comme c'est le cas
très souvent alors justement vous venez
d'évoquer les prix par n'importe quel
prix combien vont coûter les jeux
olympiques on peut regarder
chiffre 3 88 milliards de budget privé
3,2 milliards de financements publics
schématiquement on a près de 7 milliards
de budget dont 1,5 milliard de dépenses
publiques c'est trop cher pour le
contribuable français à frédéric viale
c'est pas c'est pas la question que ce
soit c'est pas la question que ce soit
trop cher c'est que pour l'instant les
budgets ne sont ni crédible ni sérieux
c'est à dire que on nous dit pour
l'instant un milliard et demi d'argent
public mais il ya un certain nombre de
choses qui ne sont pas budgétée il ya un
certain nombre de choses qui sont
budgétés ailleurs il ya certaines choses
qui sont absolument pas pris en
considération et donc du coup le 1
milliard et demi on peut pas on ne peut
pas dire que ça va être ça va être ça ça
c'est toujours la même chose si on par
exemple on au budget pas la sécurité
la sécurité ça a été un milliard à
londres donc déjà on rentre plus dans
les clous
si on budget la sécurité pourquoi ne pas
budgétée la sécurité pourquoi budgété
l'aréna 2 ailleurs pourquoi budgété
l'aréna 2 sur un autre budget en disant
que ça va servir pour le basket ball
l'accélération du grand paris ça a un
coût financier également d'accélérer ce
genre de travaux qui vont être qu'ils
doivent être terminés pour 2024 pourquoi
est-ce que ça c'est pas budgétée non
plus sur les jeux olympiques
donc à partir de là on a déjà un budget
qui n'est pas qui n'est pas sérieux donc
oui ça veut dire que nécessairement ça
va être dépassé votre avis là dessus
avant de ranger un avis très sévère qui
corrobore un peu ce que dit monsieur
vial pour moi effectivement le budget
annoncé depuis un an c'est 7 milliards
or ce budget je ne représente pas comme
une dépense c'est un investissement soit
alors on verra si l'investissement est
utile ou prioritaire ces 7 milliards
mais ça ne couvre pas à certain nombre
de dépenses indispensables pour
l'organisation des jeux je dis bien
indispensable religion du jeu la
sécurité de 100 millions de provisions
les jeux de londres on parle d'un
milliard mais on parle de 2 milliards en
réalité plus jeu à musquin sotchi
c'était 5 milliards alors qu'ils la
sécurité n'y est pas le coût des
fonctionnaires qui vont être affectés à
l'organisation des jeux n'est pas non
plus parce qu'on parle de près deux
autres 50 mille soixante mille
fonctionnaires qui peu ou prou vaut
travailler essentiellement pour
l'organisation des jeux olympiques
ceci n'est pas budgétée ce qui n'est pas
budgétée non plus
c'est un élément primordial auxquelles
on ne pense jamais on doit être prêts au
jour j à l'heure h à la seconde s et ça
ça crée une pression
quant à la livraison de ce qu'on doit
donner qui fait augmenter les prix
automatiquement donc 7 milliards c'est
un budget qui a priori paraît réaliste
mais il n'est pas exhaustif et il est
imprécis encore à cette date qu'est ce
qu'il faudra améliorer donc ce qu'il
faut améliorer avant toute chose c'est
le contrôle de ce budget et d'annoncer
clairement et ne pas attendre la
dernière minute pour savoir que l'on va
dépenser que l'on va dépasser dans des
conditions absolument incroyable quand
on pense que tokyo voilà des jeux
olympiques du japonais qui savent
organiser des jeux nous savons organiser
les jeux tokyo au départ c'était 5
milliards c'est monté jusqu'au 27
milliards et maintenant on est à 14
milliards donc ce n'est pas logique et
c'est normal et votre sondage le prouve
bien
les gens ne comprennent pas parce qu'ils
ne croient pas à ces budgets or ils ont
été élaborés sérieusement même s'il ne
faut pas été exhaustif donc ce qu'il
faudrait faire
c'est vraiment contrôlé au centime près
jour par jour ce budget est joué la
transparence complet avec tous les
acteurs qu'ils soient publics qu'ils
soient privés parce que l'on dit 50/50
public-privé d'accord 50% une
contribution du privé a eu notamment à
travers les sponsors
mais si ses sponsors c'est tous des
entreprises publiques ça change tout
c'est d'une manière ou une autre c'est
une contribution de l'état de la nation
du contribuable aux jeux olympiques et
c'est plus uniquement des fonds privés
donc ça veut dire qu'entre prévisionnel
est réelle il ya un fossé ce sacre des
rivières il ya un fossé est là où je
suis effectivement très inquiète c'est
que en plus le fossé là dont on vient de
parler il ya un contrat de ville hôte
c'est à dire y'a un contrat qui a été
signé entre le cio et paris et l'état
qui dit de manière très claire que ce
l'argent que met sur la table cio il
mettra pas un centime de plus en revance
tous les dépassements tous mes
déplacements seront à la charge du
contribuable
et donc quand on a ce genre
d'arrangement effectivement on peut
toujours dire derrière il faudra
contrôler au centime près mais le
problème c'est que là rien ne montre que
en prennent le chemin est absolument
rien puisque déjà on a un budget qui
n'est pas crédible
ensuite on nous dit que de toute façon
les
les dépenses seront mises sur le compte
des contribuables alors après ça on peut
toujours espérer qu'il y ait un contrôle
et après tout il ya des institutions qui
sont censés le faire mais on doit
craindre un dépassement tout à fait
monstrueux notamment par des dépenses
mais forcément il va y avoir des
retombées économiques en tous les cas
les projets au son tour des retombées
économiques pas ce qui a évidemment le
côté paris en pleine lumière la france
en pleine lumière pendant les jeux
olympiques tout le monde va regarder la
france donc il y aura des retombées
économiques
le monde le cds de limoges via monsieur
gayant estime entre 5,3 et 10,7
milliards d'euros les retombées
économiques de 2010 est jusqu à 2034
donc on y est déjà dedans ça fait déjà
trois ans on est en 2020 est-ce que
c'est réalisable sava frédéric viale
j'attire votre attention sur les normes
fourchette c'est plus une fourchette
c'est un râteau c'est à dire que on est
entre vous avais dit 4 millions 4,7 et
londres milliards 5,3 et 5,6 est donc
c'est véritablement quelque chose
absolument considérable qui s'est avéré
beaucoup aussi dans le temps alors que
on a un petit peu de mal à savoir ce qui
va se passer dans les six mois qui
viennent n'ont véritablement ce genre de
prévisions c'est peut-être très joli à
regarder c'est peut-être très
intéressant sur le plan intellectuel
mais avoir quelque chose aussi vaste
aussi vagues et qui s'étale sur aussi
longtemps permettez moi d'en douter
voilà maintenant il faut être totalement
pragmatique chaque fois qu'une ville où
un pays est candidat à l'organisation de
jeux olympiques pour faire passer le
projet propose mille promesses entre
autres les faits j o en soi mais ce que
je remarque c'est que jamais une fois
que les jeux se sont déroulés
quiconque fait à nous dit où une
évaluation effectivement des effets
pendant dix ans on ne voit pas on le
voit pas ceci étant je pense que
d'organiser les jeux c'est une chance
mais ça devient une malédiction si
effectivement qu'on prend pas en compte
dès maintenant l'effet jo
non c'était un appel vous l'aurez l'on
appelle votre 4 et 11 milliards c'est
effectivement c'est un râteau ce qui
montre bien que l'estimation julie rey
sont faits à la louche
même si c'était par des organismes très
sérieux je le pense bien parce que c'est
compliqué à faire
ces autres 4 et 10 milliards on parle
d'un point de pib supplémentaires on
parle de 2,6 deux cent mille emplois
récurrents il ya une promesse qui a été
fait 1
on va maintenir le budget à 6 milliards
8 7 milliards donc obligation de
maintenir ce proche ce budget ça va être
compliqué il ya une deuxième promesse
qui a été fait on va pouvoir mobiliser
tous les français derrière parce que si
on me dise pas les procès derrière c'est
une catastrophe
les françaises seront mobilisés mais ce
que ça va profiter aux français non il
faut les mobiliser par des axes de
communication
compatible avec le budget des géo et à
une troisième chose et c'est ça le juge
de paix c'est l'effet gio véritablement
hors l'effet géo vous est très clair les
pays où c'est quoi c'est effectivement
les emplois le pib mais c'est toute la
promesse qui a été fait en sorte que les
personnes en situation de handicap soit
plus intégrés dans la société notamment
au niveau du transport
c'est le sport à l'école c'est faire en
sorte que la france de la nation de deux
points mais ce n'est possible que si
vous investissez dès aujourd'hui dans
les faits géo et l'effet jo faut pas se
faire d'illusions un effet un euro des
faits géo nécessite un euro
d'investissement
or il faut des investissements au niveau
de l'organisation mais il faut aussi
faire des investissements au niveau de
la pga or aujourd'hui quand on sait quel
est le budget de la provence en la
matière et le déficit hydrique
c'est compliqué on parle de pouvoir
aider ensuite la population française
via les infrastructures qui vont être
construites
on parle beaucoup de la seine saint
denis va y avoir beaucoup de sites dans
le département du 93 notamment le
village olympique qui vont devenir à
terme des habitations à ce que les
français vont bénéficier de ces futures
infrastructures frédéric viale ya
effectivement des infrastructures qui
sont prévues on parle d'une piscine
olympique et on nous dit va ça va
permettre aux enfants de pouvoir nager
et puis c'est très bien que ça permet
aux enfants d'apprendre à nager parce
qu'être positif ça c'est un point
positif puisque un sur deux en plus des
enfants qui sont en seine-saint-denis ne
savent pas nager arrivé en sixième donc
c'est très bien de faire une piscine
olympique
après la question se pose est-ce que
pour le même prix on aurait peu plus
vite fait et plus intérêt à avoir fait
trois ou quatre piscines qui serait
beaucoup plus facile
d'usagé pour pour les gens plutôt que
cet énorme piscine piscine olympique
s'ils voulaient à chaque fois on retombe
sur la même chose c'est-à-dire on
retourne sur le fait qu' on va faire des
infrastructures qui sont adaptés pour le
gigantisme de jeu qui vont durer 15
jours en essayant de faire croire que ça
va bénéficier ensuite à la population
c'est exactement la même chose sur les
sur les déplacements on nous dit les
déplacements on va avoir des bus une
flotte de bus verts qui vont pouvoir
faire que trois millions de personnes
qui sont attendues vont pouvoir se
déplacer montrait bien qu'est-ce qu'on
en fait ensuite de cette flotte là on
continue d'utiliser avec 3 millions de
personnes en moins et enfin vous voyez à
chaque fois on est sur des choses qui
sont absolument surdimensionné qui ont
été réfléchies pour les jeux et dont on
essaie de le faire quoi qu'elles vont
être qu'elles sont réfléchies pour pour
les personnes concernées il ya toujours
eu un problème et quand on voit la
manière dont je travaille aussi avec le
comité de vigilance dans le 93 quand on
voit la manière dont les consultations
population se passe c'est à dire en gros
les gens leur demande leur avis puis
finalement on n'en tient pas compte du
tout on peut effectivement se poser et
s'interroger fortement sur le fait que
ces infrastructures vont effectivement
profité aux populations pas dans les
débats sur la je vous contredit un peu
il ya une préoccupation quand même on
sait qu'on sonne l'environnement et
l'écologie d'une part et deuxièmement la
notion d'héritage damnation piscine
c'est un serpent de mer depuis 20 ans 30
ans je n'entends que ça on aura la
magnifique piscine olympique digne de
nos athlètes et ainsi de suite
or c'est pas le cas cette province ne
sera pas tenu et on a décidé d'avoir une
piscine olympique deux modèles réduits
mais on va multiplier un certain nombre
de petites piscines si je peux dire au
niveau du territoire principalement en
seine-saint-denis
cela va représenter un coût important
parce que exploiter une piscine et en
exploiter 8 c'est pas même coup ensuite
le point de vue et l'exploitation ça
c'est le premier chauffe
il ya une deuxième chose qui va être un
élément politique majeure comment
vraiment majeur
les efforts que font aujourd'hui les
organisations religieuses et ils peuvent
pas faire autrement c'est de les insérer
véritablement dans la politique
municipale
la politique de la ville de paris et la
politique de la région c'est à dire que
vous rendez en quelque sorte les jeux
olympiques l organisation otage des
ambitions et des objectifs tout à fait
légitime d'une région où d'une ville et
non là il peut y avoir conflit important
à se faire payer par les jeux cette
ambition politique qu'elle soit
écologique qu'elle soit sportive qu'elle
soit au niveau d'éducation et c'est un
problème majeur il le faut parce qu'on
ne peut pas organiser les jeux sans le
rôle majeur que peut avoir le maire et
en l'occurrence lorsque vous avez une
personne aussi déterminé que peut l'être
anne hidalgo ça doit être pris en compte
complètement donc là il ya un débat
pénalisant si je peux dire si on n'a pas
les moyens véritablement d'intégrer
l'organisation des jeux dans la
politique municipale ou dans les petites
régional et qui plus est pour la
mobilisation à ce niveau là il peut y
avoir une confusion pour tout acteur
diddy bâtonnets moi je suis pour les
jeunes mais je suis contre la politique
municipale
donc elle comment je me je me positionne
c'est un vaste problème au niveau de la
mobilisation qui est indispensable pour
qu'elle soit réussie
vaste problème vaste débat on continue
d'en parler dans la deuxième partie de
notre match a tout suite
de retour sur le plateau de l'autre
match pour parler des jeux de paris
c'est dans moins de 1600 jour sur ce
plateau à nos invités n'ont pas bougé
frédéric viale du collectif non aux jeux
olympiques de paris 2024 et armand de
rands 1 g consultant sportif et de
l'olympisme
on parlait armand à l'instant notamment
des jeux durable des jeux verts il ya
une passe d'armes l'été dernier entre la
maire de paris la mère du parti
socialiste anne hidalgo et le président
emmanuel macron au sujet de total du
sponsoring de cette entreprise au niveau
des jeux olympiques
regardez ce qu'elle a dit anne hidalgo
serait très difficilement compréhensible
pour nos concitoyens qu'il soit retenu
des entreprises dans l'activité aurait
un lourd impact sur l'environnement en
se fondant notamment sur le recours
massif à des énergies carbonées et la
réponse du berger à la bergère emmanuel
macron ensuite
qui déclare c'est plus difficile de
l'écarter de l'argent privé en donnant
des leçons de morale que d'en trouver
donc maintenant on doit mobiliser
collectivement tous les financeurs
français quid de l'impact de
de l'environnement sur les jeux de paris
on parle de 50 5% l'impact carbone de
moins que les jeux de nantes par exemple
frédéric viale ça c'est plutôt un
argument pour oui enfin moi j'appelle ça
de la flûte c'est à dire que on est là
la fois être clair c'est à dire que
aussi bien les estimations qui ont été
faites après les jeux de londres
ça relève du doigt mouillé maintenant
ensuite les affirmations qui sont fait
trop lagos idoine oui mais moi je
constate une chose c'est qu'on nous dit
il va y avoir trois millions de
personnes qui vont venir il va y avoir
des bâtiments bas carbone et il va
l'avoir de l'économie circulaire bref
tous ces arguments qu'on trouve pour
dire que les jeux ça va être très bien
sur le plan sur le plan environnemental
je constate que la mairie de paris donne
des extensions là encore très récemment
pour la construction d'une usine lafarge
de 2 de 3 c'est d'ailleurs d'une usine à
béton sur les bords de seine
et je me pose la question pourquoi là
tout simplement parce qu'il ya besoin de
faire des infrastructures en béton pour
les infrastructures de transport
notamment pour l'accélération du grand
paris donc moi je me dis oui enfin on
peut nous promettre tout ce qu'on nous
veut sur la compensation carbone les
labellisations wwf et ce genre de choses
en tous les cas moi ce que je constate
c'est que on n'a jamais autant autant
bétonné et que si il y à d'un seul coup
autant besoin de béton c'est qu'il va
bien falloir servir à quelque chose
mais les les jeux olympiques c'est
peut-être un accélérateur pour rendre
une ville plus verte non à rendre en
danger c'est l'ambition du comité à ta
salle olympique du cio qui se rend
compte que devant la désertion de toutes
les candidatures aujourd'hui il ya de
moins en moins paris los angeles son
candidat bon los angele se place sur le
plan technologique
mais le cio a donné comme feuille de
route un ville de paris vous êtes une
ville traditionnelle contrainte au point
de vue de l'organisation
mais il faut que vous ré que vous
répondiez à est vraiment une ambition
écologique
anne hidalgo répond à cette ambition
alors je ne sais pas si c'est une simple
promesse en l'air ou pas du tout mais
elle est quand même convaincu que sur
l'objectif c'est qu'en 2030 la capitale
de la france paris soit la ville
référence en matière de
de l'environnement si je peux dire donc
une ville verte en matière de transport
nouveau et elle considère que les jeux
olympiques peut être un catalyseur et un
booster fantastique pour cela or c'est
très très compliqué parce que les
entreprises ne sont pas prêtes à
accepter le même la même ambition
donc il peut y avoir un hiatus la sphère
total en étude n'a une auto cissé airbnb
il ya une politique hôtelière qu'on aime
ou qu'on n'aime pas à paris ok et bien
aimé est arrivé avec une autre politique
hôtelière ça pose un problème
or ça représente des millions et des
millions d'euros à un petit peu
intéressant pour le budget des jeux
olympiques
d'où la passe d'armes entre emmanuel
macron et anne hidalgo
donc on l'a bien compris en courses et
jeux de paris s'est évité les écueils de
londres de rio notamment oui moi même
d'athènes regardez ce qui s'est passé du
côté de ses jeux olympiques là et
comment essayer de voir l'avenir là
c'est un sujet de clément des cours tous
les deux ans et trois semaines de gloire
et d'émerveillement pour que la plupart
des sites soit ensuite laissée à
l'abandon voilà la triste vie des
infrastructures olympiques
faute d'argent et d'entretien certaines
d'entre elles sont désormais infestée
par la moisissure et les murs lézardés
par les fissures
c'est le cas des infrastructures
brésilienne où règne une ambiance post
apocalyptique
en chine également pour rappel 44
milliards de dollars avaient été
investis pour construire ces édifices
en grèce la nature semble avoir repris
ses droits sur le parcours de kayak et
pour éviter cela pari qui semble avoir
pris exemple sur barcelone la ville
catalane a profité des jeux 92 pour
améliorer son réseau de transport elle a
aussi su se servir des nouvelles
installations pour accueillir des
événements sportifs internationaux
le comité d'organisation parisien a
annoncé que le village olympique sera
reconvertis en habitations
ce qui permettrait de répondre à la
pénurie de logements en ile-de-france
répondre à la pénurie de logements en
ile-de-france pour essayer de rendre
pérenne des infrastructures olympiques
dans deux côtés on sait que les jeux
d'athènes sur les 22 sites olympiques 20
sont laissés à l'abandon
comment éviter de tomber dans les
écueils grec londoniens ou ouvriers lien
fait par dispensable à ce qu'on appelle
les fameuses éléphants blancs et puis
les jeux que ce soit les bâtiments de
hatten ou du brésil c'est une
catastrophe c'est évident
si vous regardez toute l'histoire des
jeux cette situation n'est pas aussi un
peu quelle victime mais en règle
générale on a toujours un énorme
problème au niveau de l'héritage
barcelone est un succès parce que
barcelone a annoncé la couleur dès le
départ je veux sortir de l'isolément
sportif et je veux montrer qu'une ville
comme barcelone peut organiser des jeux
qui ont été précieux et c'est sans doute
les jeux les mieux organisés ou la
promesse a été remplie si je me permets
d'être un petit peu plus long c'est qu'à
chaque fois pour chaque jeu il y avait
une ambition vous prenez le japon en
1964 il fallait sortir de l'isolément
dans lequel de l'après guerre et puis la
nouvelle technologie ou prenez signer en
2000 s'était créé des jeux verbe sur un
continent très très lointain ou prenez
séoul en 1988 il fallait montrer
clairement que la corée du sud pouvait
sortir d'une dictature
donc il y avait une ambition politique
au travers des jeux au niveau de paris
il ya une ambition qui est celle de
faire des jeux sublime extraordinaire
fantastique verts et ee et montrait que
la partie verte à partie
environnementale est vraiment prise en
compte mais c'est une ambition qui n'est
qu'une forme de promesses donc comment
comment la réaliser
et faire en sorte qu'on y arrive c'est
un problème budgétaire et de volonté et
de vandalisme
or aujourd'hui ce dont tahri ce n'est
pas forcément partagée par tout le monde
et on n'a pas forcément les moyens
c'est ça le problème les les jeux de
paris ne peuvent pas être un catalyseur
justement pour faire en sorte que paris
devienne plus vers essayer de trouver un
objectif comme le diamant de rands 1 g
pour un objectif une ambition le climat
par exemple pour faire évoluer les
villes dans le futur oui bien sûr on
peut on peut toujours habillé de toutes
les deux tous les discours les objectifs
qui peuvent être tenues c'est à dire
qu'on peut très bien dire oui on atteint
l'objectif on attelle de ce point de vue
d'ailleurs certainement paris fait
beaucoup plus attention que ses
prédécesseurs aux questions vers non
seulement parce que c'est à la mode mais
aussi parce que le cio s'est quand même
aperçu a senti passer le vent du boulet
ça a été dit tout à l'heure
paris était la seule ville pratiquement
qui restait puisque toutes les villes se
sont désistés les unes derrière les
autres devant l'ampleur des défis que
posent
les jeux les jeux olympiques ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire qu'à l'avenir il
y aura plus de candidatures c'est ça
c'est pas programme bah c'est pas un
probable dans la mesure où dans tous les
cas personnellement c'est ce que c'est
ce que j'espère dans la mesure où on se
rend compte qu'à chaque fois il y a des
conséquences qui n'ont pas été mesuré à
l'avant mais donc paris sa part des fois
je vais être d'accord avec avec monsieur
tout à l'heure vous avez dit il s'agit
une promesse politique qui va s'agir etc
etc
on est là dedans c'est à dire on est
dans la promesse alors c'est bien gentil
les promesses mais quand il s'agit de
les mettre en oeuvre
on s'aperçoit surtout quand il s'agit de
mettre en oeuvre avec de budget derrière
on s'aperçoit que c'est s'est jamais mis
en place et puis des promesses dans
laquelle on nous dit par exemple que on
va avoir des logements le village
olympique va être transformée en
logements
on se dit bon c'est moins pire mais est
ce qu on sait aussi que l'article 18 de
la loi olympique invite les offices hlm
à financer 40 % de village olympique
c'est à dire que enfin c'est quand même
un signe c'est comme une bombe ce genre
de choses c'est à dire que 40% du coût
du village olympique va être financé par
les office public hlm à un moment où
l'on connaît une crise du logement très
forte et il n'est rien dit sur la
transformation du village olympique en
en bâtiment où il va y avoir des
habitations des habitations de famille
qui va financer ça tout ça vous voyez il
ya tout un tas de choses comme ça qui se
met en place et qui permettent de douter
très très fortement de ce type de
promesses et de se dire est-ce que
simplement n'est pas dans le discours
est tout à l'heure j'ai utilisé le mot à
mot un peu brutal mais je me demande si
on n'est pas dans la flûte alors je n'ai
pas on est honnête je n'avais pas de
reflet c'est le problème majeur est le
problème de la transformation d'un
village des médias ou d'un village des
athlètes en logements sociaux par la
suite est une belle promesse
elle était indispensable même dans la
région notamment de département de la
seine saint denis mais le modèle
économique que l'on propose est
totalement aberrant n'a aucune
signification ou ne peut pas réaliser ce
modèle on ne peut pas y répondre d'une
manière positive pour raison bien simple
c'est que vous installez un village
trois mille 3000 logements vous le
transformer ipso facto le mètre carré
prend des ampleurs colossal et tu
découvert un déplacement des
déplacements de population il sera pas
forcément la population locale
s'adresserait c'est assez ces
appartements qui pourront bénéficier ses
vingt ans à londres c'est le canari
pique ça veut dire que le
la seine saint denis où il ya des
quartiers populaires ça va devenir des
quartiers ça peut des quartiers
bourgeois comme est et l'est de l'aude
qui avait fait le même lame la même
chose avec le même modèle en disant on
va transformer tout un quartier très
très bien on va le sortir de la
salubrité des difficultés on va mettre
en place des logements
et puis on va avoir une majorité
logements dits sociaux avec une certaine
mixité avec des logements un peu plus
prestigieux entre guillemets puis-je
aller plus loin parce que là ce que vous
dites je vais être d'accord avec vous et
je vais dire qu'il y a en plus de ce que
vous avez dit des conséquences induites
c'est que vous avez dit il va y avoir
des populations et je suis assez
d'accord avec ça qu'ils vont être des
populations relativement aisée qui vont
s'installer là mais ça veut dire que les
populations qui sont actuellement vont
aller plus loin et donc on va aboutir à
quelque chose qui est un déplacement des
populations vers l'extérieur est
toujours plus loin dans la très grande
banlieue ce qui va impliquer une
multiplication des déplacements et là on
est dans des pollutions induites et de
très long terme qui sont des pollutions
très importante et a par après on nous
parle de jeux verts mais on ne regarde
jamais les conséquences sur le très long
terme et c'est quand même dommage et sa
table à rentrer dans le modèle
économique
quand vous parliez des critères qui
était compliqué je vous posais la
question est ce que les candidatures y
en aura de moins en moins à l'avenir moi
il dit très probablement mais est ce que
ça veut dire que la candidature de paris
est un choix par défaut
alors ça a été un choix par rapport est
par défaut puisque ils ont attribué les
jeux de 24 2 bat 8 à paris à los angeles
mais là on le sait le mouvement
olympique connaît un véritable tournant
aujourd'hui et ça va être une pression
majeure sur paris paris et la france
s'est organisé les jeux ya pas qu il n'y
a pas de souci pour cela mais il faut
les organiser selon les contraintes dont
on a parlé jusqu'à maintenant
car si elles ne respectent pas ces
contraintes si elles dépassent les
budgets s'il n'y a pas de mobilisation
s'ils ne sont pas verts et tout le monde
se plaint qu'ils n'étaient pas
suffisamment vert je pense qu'il n'y
aura pratiquement plus de candidatures
ensuite en tous les cas le débat est
ouvert mais il ne plaque pas clos et
évidemment il reste encore mille cent
mille six cent jours à peu près avant
que
ni à la cérémonie d'ouverture du côté de
paris pour les jeux olympiques merci
beaucoup monsieur d'être intervenu sur
le plateau de l'autre match merci
frédéric mercier rarement de rands 1 g
on se donne rendez vous la semaine
prochaine pour une nouvelle émission
l'autre match d'ici là vous pouvez
revivre celle ci en replay en podcast
sur arte france point tv excellente
journée ou en soirée à tous sur arte
france ne paye merci
[Musique]